life on Mars what would it take to
support human life on this planet well
it's a tough question to answer
according to NASA living on Mars could
happen with the existence of three
elements water nitrogen and oxygen water
is the bare minimum requirement to
sustain human life the Mars orbiter has
confirmed vast deposits of it in the
North and South Poles as well as below
the surface then there's food a nitrogen
is key and growing it
there isn't enough nitrate in Mars soil
to nurture life but some scientists say
greenhouses could be built to grow
plants and Mars is so cold that it
produces carbon dioxide snow this frozen
carbon dioxide or dry ice could be
converted into oxygen by solidifying it
and releasing it back into the
atmosphere but here's the problem
powerful solar winds strip away most of
the planet's atmosphere sending it off
into space so making the red plant at a
place where humans can live is even
tougher than previously thought but
these facts haven't stopped a Dutch team
from creating Mars 1 a mission to Mars
that will send four astronauts on a
one-way trip
to live and establish the first human
colony by 2026